[Musique]
les
angers caen aventure les appels
en corée l'inde tel beau pays j'y suis
allé en vacances une fois c'est fou je
te jure là bas il y vingt trois fois
rien et ils ont quand même le sourire ça
fait réfléchir
mais retrouvons plutôt elliott notre ami
robots et sa nouvelle amie cadets 29
qu'ils aient leurs méchants patrons
que veut-il encore modifier dans le
temps mais j'en sais rien c'est si
horrible de ne rien savoir comme un
simple moniteur 7e siècle dans le palais
de l'empereur un peu tôt limitrophes
pourquoi tu dis ça désolé c'est un
réflexe mais étrange et vous que faites
vous de l'autre palais chair mortelle
je suis une divinité une divinité nous
nous prosternons devant tu vois le
meilleur moyen d'obtenir ce qu'on veut
c'est de se faire passer pour des dieux
seul problème c'est quand ils changent
et passent leur temps à nous donner à
manger manger
j'aimerais ressentir le goût des choses
de les grands dieux métalliques
voici notre meilleur plat ce sont des
agneaux élevés en musique nourrit
d'herbe arrosées de lait aux miennes ont
leur masse le crâne et les pattes en
leur disant qu'ils sont les plus hautes
piles sont cuisinés par nos meilleurs
chefs super allez mettons ces cadavres
de bébés moutons dans nos orifices pique
au mastic on est jusqu'à en faire une
bouillie un fort merci à vous peuple
indien cette année on est à la fois
court c'est avec un arôme boissy écoute
notre requête si tu ne veux pas nous
courroucé à tout ce que vous nous tordre
au nom afin de nous satisfait d'abord
une chanson tu es descendu
les plus précieux de mille feux lui
maîtrise logging le gang
je maîtrise toutes les notes merci à
vous je vous demande ne peut être ton
égard
me la souveraine à l'époque un plus
banal quelles consignes en métal
pourquoi ils disent que je suis ton
esclave qu'une idée humain voilà notre
requête
donnez-nous votre livre le plus précieux
le kama sutra au je vois de quel livre
vous parle d'un god of war ou que je
m'ennuie
moyrand malice bosch et donc l'équation
no rick bass l'autre main faut que tu
t'accroches jour mon brave plus
longtemps one
oui exactement voilà je crois qu'on est
proche
tu passe au-dessus jazz de gerba genou
console ça c'est fastoche
tu vas pas besoin de l'être agban oui
oui c'est bien ça est-ce que vous pouvez
le bar le duc à mazout rome on avait
compris arrêté de chanter et onema ce
livre tenez c'est notre seul exemplaire
fait des attentions ouais tu vois
c'était facile allez elliot on s'en va
ok allons-y maintenant y'a plus qu'à
détruire le kama sutra et la mission est
accomplie fait voir le livre ses barons
ce que font ces humains ils sont souples
n'empêche
tu veux qu'on essaye d une position qu
est ce que tu racontes c'est juste pour
rigoler genre pour se moquer des humains
étant pratiqué le coït aveugle non non
c'était pour rigoler et n'impacte pas
les robots sont vraiment supérieurs à
ces imbéciles d'êtres humains on n'a pas
besoin de manger et pas besoin de se
reproduire
nous ne sommes pas ralenti parce qu'ils
appellent des émotions ben oui c'est nul
les émotions même leur café ils ne
savent pas fait tout seul
si tu devais encore servir un café latté
frappé un humain future es tu es libre
maintenant inutile de te retenir de tuer
des humains
non c'est pas ça c'est juste que je ne
savais pas que tu faisais des cafés
frappés à toi si c'est enfin je fais du
café et après il faut le mettre dans un
congélateur puis des cafés frappés grâce
à mon système
système de glaciation original cabine 29
voté pour gaby 29 100 fois plus
d'options que kb 20 tu lis un café une
révolution 100 fois plus d'options
maintenant allons voir notre chef
elle va s'impatienter elle tâche a fait
d'une femme oui je suis pressé de la
présenter tu vas voir
elle est super programment la
destination temporel pendant que je
détruis du kama sutra
ok oui parce que je fais aussi broyeur
de documents il doit y avoir une erreur
la destination que tu m'as donné épine
chez papa le docteur ciment c'est notre
ennemi mais justement notre chef est
intelligente elle sait que le dernier
endroit où ces fauteurs de troubles vont
la chercher
c'est sous leur nez sauf s'ils cherchent
une moustache
en conséquence notre base est juste au
dessus du laboratoire du professeur bon
allons-y je t'expliquerai canton sera
légal c'est vraiment bizarre bizarre
ciao
siècle dans un palais impérial du jardin
bon on n'oublie pas mes cinq étoiles et
d'euros non non on les a encore raté
c'était mon des amis de faire pourquoi
il est parti
regarde par terre cerveau c'est
l'écriture d'elliot j'en reconnais c'est
du times new roman 12 cher thomas c'est
vraiment bizarre bizarre bizarre rejoint
vite au dessus du laboratoire de mon
papa ça fait plaisir de revenir ce genre
aventure complètement tordue avec vos
laboratoires de mon père mais pourquoi
bon on doit commencer par quitter cette
époque qu'est ce que les robots encore
déréglé c'est dans une cabine parisiens
nous ont pris ces images et les grands
si doux écolo grand livre du zizi à
mittal du canada du kama sutra
quand c'est en chanson je comprends mais
si l'on fait disparaître le kama sutra
c'est là que j'interviens dans l'émoi de
quoi dessiner et je vous refais le kama
sutra voilà tenez voici du papier une
plume et de l'anc
alors le bond du tigre le 69 un grand
classement en attendant le pig hoa et
binh la levrette la graine germée la
grimpe à l'arbre
le repos du guerrier le lotus quand dany
tu connais tout ça je me suis beaucoup
document thomas pour que tu me donnes
une copie du livre étoile du matin le
partout piqueur les ciseaux le poiré
indien et je vous rajoute quelques
positions que j'ai inventé mais que j'ai
pas encore pratiqué tout j'en ai
pratiqué aucune aide quelles
connaissances débordante tomates un
génie tel et mes amis
voici le kama sutra 2.0 extended version
directeur ce que tu fais
l'avez vous avez réussi c'est grâce à la
grande culture de dommage ça avec mes
heures sur le nouveau tsar ya là quelque
chose d'autre que de nous faire part des
lapins ramène de tout de suite au
laboratoire unibail petit animal éthique
soit en pour allégations
pourtant au laboratoire génial de aulas
a fait long tort mais qu'est ce que tu
fais là au bâton pour sa part la
personne qu'on cherche
celle qui modifient mi temps et juste
ici chez moi
manon écouter ça vient mais j'entends
une voix de femme leur chef doit être là
vous êtes prêts dont on y va on est des
masses qui leur dit nous ont trouvés
qu'est ce que mérite ma soeur jumelle
moi je sais pas qui c'est un vrai bras
c'est moi mais emma thomas iris
je viens de découvrir qui est l'ennemi
depuis le début c'est une autre héroïne
autres warcq et plus en plus n'importe
quoi iris 2 tu étais là depuis le début
et oui juste soute on est pauvre
imbécile et arrête de m'appeler
christophe super
à des intégrateurs proton pour être
précise plus personne ne bouge
mon cher papa du monde réel on dirait
que tu n'as pas tout expliquer à ton
équipe
papa pourquoi j'ai un double qui nous
menace avec un flingue et qui veut
détruire le monde je produis je vous en
ai pas parlé tout de suite parce que
j'avais peur que vous le preniez malone
mais fait toujours à continuer
oui j'écoute quoi c'est la fin de
l'épisode
non mais sérieux les gars ça peut
pas s'arrêter comme ça je veux savoir
pourquoi il y a deux iris en soutenant
colle sans l'étrange démissionne merci
d'avoir écouté est la semaine prochaine
pour le neuvième épisode de l'épopée
temporel